I judge people all the time.
I judge working moms.
Why do you have to leave every night by this certain time?
Why aren't you married?
Now that you have a baby, are you going to get married?
I will never let my kid do that.
My kid will never misbehave in a restaurant.
I think I'm desensitized almost...
...because people talk about whether or not I breastfeed or bottle feed so much.
A lot of the choices that I make for my baby I have to fight for it...
...so when I see someone doing the opposite I definitely find myself judging them.
It's very easy to be judgmental of others...
...and I think that's why people are judgmental because it really is easy.